i i had a question that was keeping me
up last night
um i read this book uh was it the
pleiadians have you heard about that
yeah yeah i know yeah like i wrote it
i [ __ ] i i [ __ ] a pleiadian it was
gnarly
it's the gnarliest things i've ever done
um
this book uh i forget the the lady who
wrote it but she was speaking to the
pleiadians and uh there was this theory
presented in this book which i read
which was that uh
junk dna if you've heard of this yeah
okay so scientists refer to
some
90
of our genetic makeup of our dna as junk
dna they cannot understand what the what
purpose it serves we only use
there's only they can only identify
ten percent of our dna as actually
having anything to do with us as
orchestras
and the theory in this book was that
uh
that entities at one point found uh
humans to be
uh dangerous you know uh capable of too
much disruption and
went in and unplugged our dna because
the purpose the theory is that the
purpose of the junk dna 90 of our dna
was actually
uh
that that was what made us
interdimensional beings
and so by unplugging our dna we no
longer operated
in uh
in a higher frequency or something yeah
in other dimensions
and uh and by by relegating us to
simply this 3d experience then like
without that
without that dna plugged in like
we now kind of feel
we don't understand why like why we're
here like yeah
like we're kind of just in the dark like
they rendered us yeah impotent in some
kind of life yeah i don't doubt aversion
like that at all i mean i'm not a
geneticist obviously anymore
but um
but yeah i mean i think like the way it
looks like to me barbara marciniak she
was the arthur the way it looks like to
me is that something came here and
tampered with dna and all the chimeras
and all that weird [ __ ] you see on
pyramid walls it's like half man half
bull and all this weird [ __ ] um even
when you look at the ancient sumerian
texts it talks a lot about those who
from heaven to earth came and you know
they created a slave species and so
there's nephilim the nephilim was part
yes the giants of the bible all that
kind of stuff you know because the the
the the fallen angels took women for
wives and had give birth to giants i
mean there's a whole
series of stories and color that we can
paint with that someone [ __ ] with our
dna and i and i tend to think like
that there's something that's been
cyclical on earth where civilizations
rise and fall in these tower of babel
type moments where they will be as god
strike them down change their languages
and all this weird [ __ ]
i i really believe there's truth to all
that that as soon as we let off a
nuclear weapon boom they show up again
wow we were you know we put all these
kids in a zoo and now they're building
bombs we gotta [ __ ] we gotta figure to
sit out it's called stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah yeah dude